With some of the biggest stars and most famous
characters in the world, Marvel movies are
awesome.
The stories are fun, the action is remarkable
and the dialogue between the characters is
surprisingly funny.
With tons of movies coming out each year,
it can be easy to miss an important moment
or two, but that’s what we’re here for!
For this video we are taking a look at 10
Moments In Marvel Superhero Movies That Mean
More Than You Think.
Enjoy this list and be sure to hit the subscribe
button to get brand new Screen Rant content,
every single day!
Spider-Man Line - Ant-Man
Fans are eagerly awaiting the release of Spiderman
Homecoming in 2017, but there was a time (not
too long ago) when bringing Spidey to the
MCU was just a dream.
When news broke that Spider-Man would be joining
the MCU, it didn’t take long for Marvel
to reference him in one of their movies.
While we didn't see the webslinger in 2015’s
Ant-Man, he was definitely mentioned.
Near the end of the film, Anthony Mackie’s
Falcon mentions that he's looking for "a guy
with mad skills."
He is then told that there is, “A guy who
jumps, a guy who swings, a guy who crawls."
This, of course, was a pretty clear allusion
to Spiderman, even if they didn’t outright
say his name.
It was a quick moment that carried more weight
than fans may have thought as it officially
confirmed that Spidey was on his way!
Blind Al - Deadpool
2016’s Deadpool definitely took the entire
world by storm, but with all the hype, one
surprisingly important character may have
slipped through the cracks.
Just like in the comic books, Ryan Reynolds’
Deadpool rooms with a woman named Blind Al.
Al is a minor character in the film, only
appearing in a small number of humorous scenes,
but in the comics, Al is a much more important
character.
Not only did Wade Wilson spare her life, when
he was hired to kill her in his mercenary
days, but she then also acts as his guide,
trying to keep him on a heroic path.
On top of all that, she also serves to connect
Deadpool with the rest of the Marvel universe,
as she was actually an old girlfriend of Captain
America during his WWII days!
Although Blind Al is mostly a comedic device
in the film, her back-story is no laughing
matter.
Captain America’s Shield – Iron Man, Iron
Man 2
Captain America’s Vibranium shield is one
of the most iconic and recognizable items
in the entire Marvel universe.
The shield has made regular appearances in
the MCU ever since we first got to meet the
super soldier in Captain America: The First
Avenger – but fans with a keen eye were
able to spot a prototype version of it twice
before that.
This was of course important because it was
foreshadowing the coming of the Cap to the
budding franchise.
In Iron Man, the prototype could be seen lying
around in Tony Stark’s workshop and, later,
in Iron Man 2, it was seen again, when it
was picked up by Phil Coulson and subsequently
used by Stark to prop up his homemade particle
accelerator.
Both of these moments can easily be missed,
but for true fans that were able to catch
them, they were an exciting tease at to what
was coming next.
Gauntlet Reveal - Thor
While Thor’s movies may not be regarded
as the best Marvel films out there, they definitely
serve a purpose and have had some pretty important
moments hidden in them as well.
There's a scene in the original Thor film
where they are walking through Odin's mighty
hall and as they pass different artifacts
on display, the Infinity Gauntlet can be seen
in the distance.
This is of course the giant gold glove that
Thanos wears in order to wield the power of
all six infinity stones.
It would make sense for Odin to have the gauntlet
for safekeeping.
It was, of course, revealed in the Age of
Ultron mid-credits scene that Thanos now has
the gauntlet and is going after the stones,
but the question of how he got it is still
a mystery.
With the presence of the gauntlet in Thor,
we have to think that Loki helped Thanos is
some way or another.
Ten Rings – Ant Man
Back in the first Iron Man, Tony was attacked
and captured by a terrorist organization known
as the Ten Rings and fans of the comics knew
that meant that The Mandarin was coming.
Fast forward through all the nonsense of Iron
Man 3 and the confusing explanation of the
Marvel one shot All Hail The King and fans
had to think that they weren’t going to
hear more about The Mandarin and Ten Rings.
Then, Ant Man came along and dropped a sneaky
bomb on all of us.
Towards the end of the film, there was a bodyguard
waiting for Darren Cross on a helipad.
If you looked closely at the man, you saw
that he had a neck tattoo protruding from
his collar and if you looked even closer,
you could see that that the tattoo was the
insignia of the Ten Rings.
Marvel doesn’t do anything by accident and
we have to think that this means that Ten
Rings and maybe even The Mandarin is set to
return!
New Captain America – Captain America Civil
War
In the comics, Steve Rogers isn't Captain
America forever and it is actually his pal,
Bucky Barnes who takes up the role after Rogers
is gone.
There have been many shots of Bucky Barnes
wielding the shield, which has caused fans
to speculate that he will become Captain America
soon or later.
Many fans thought that Captain America: Civil
War could end with Rogers giving up the mantle
to Barnes, but we now know that to be false.
That being said, Chris Evans only has a couple
more movies left on his Marvel contract, whereas
Sebastian Stan is signed on for eight more
film.
This fact, along with the teasing shots of
Barnes with the famous shield, and we have
to think that there will be a new Captain
America coming soon enough.
Adam Warlock Cocoon - Thor: The Dark World/Guardians
of the Galaxy
The post-credits scene at the end of Thor:
The Dark World was really weird.
While it was meant to set up Guardians of
the Galaxy and the Infinity Gauntlet, it was
tonally very out of place and downright bizarre,
as moviegoers are introduced to the Collector
and his vast collection of intergalactic oddities.
One of the things hidden in this scene appears
to be Adam Warlock, the "perfect" human who,
in the comics, eventually made his way to
space and became a very powerful comic being.
He plays a large role in Marvel's Infinity
Gauntlet comic storyline and he actually also
showed up in Guardians Of The Galaxy in his
cocoon form.
As of right now, we don’t know what all
this means, but we know that it is definitely
important as it has shown up twice.
Spiderman Webbed Wings
When it was revealed that Iron Man would be
working with Spiderman in his solo movie,
fans began to theorize about what possible
Stark industry tech the webslinger might be
getting his hands on.
When the trailer for Spiderman Homecoming
dropped, there was one moment that answered
a lot of peoples questions.
The trailer showed Spiderman with some webbed
wings, and fans of the comics instantly recognized
them as a big part of Spidey’s history.
While the wings had first been mostly decorative,
they have become more and more functional
over the years giving Spidey the ability to
glide through the air with ease.
Tom Holland’s Spider-Man will face off against
Vulture (played by Michael Keaton) in Homecoming,
so it seems fitting that the Stark-designed
suit will give Spider-Man a little extra help
against his flying nemesis.
S.H.I.E.L.D.'s map – Iron Man 2
The MCU is famous for dropping hints and teases
for stuff years in advance and it all started
with the Iron Man franchise.
There are lots of important moments like this
in the films but perhaps no instance provided
more information as to Marvel’s plans than
this scene from Iron Man 2.
As Tony Stark meets Nick Fury at the end of
the film, a map can be seen in the background
with red hotspots highlighted.
From their positions, you can see that they
seem to indicate the locations of superheroes,
including one in Africa, which we now know
was pointing to Wakanda, the land of Black
Panther, and one in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean.
The second one has yet to be confirmed, but
many fans have speculated that this is a tease
for Atlantis and Namor The Submariner.
Nebula - Guardians of the Galaxy
Fans collectively lost their minds when Guardians
Of The Galaxy premiered and turned out to
be one of Marvel’s best movies to date.
While the core crew of Guardians got most
of the attention, fans should know that there
was another character in the film that will
be more important than they think in the coming
films.
Audiences could easily have forgot Karen Gillan’s
Nebula, but that would be extremely foolish.
Not only will she switch sides to join the
titular team in the 2017 Guardians sequel,
but she could also be a key character in the
Infinity War movie saga.
In the comic books, she plays a major role
in defeating Thanos, so that could very well
happen in the movies as well.
So, for all those casual fans who thought
she was just a one-off character, think again.
So there you have it, there is our list of
10 marvel superhero movie moments that totally
mean more than you think.
Which one of these moments caught you off
guard?
What other Marvel moments do you think fans
should re-watch?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
section below and be sure to subscribe to
Screen Rant for more fun videos – like this
one!